ich habe eingangs noch mal die Situation
aus Upahl geschildert das ist dieses
1600 seelendorff Gemeinde wo ein
Containerdorf errichtet werden sollte im
Moment gibt es ein Baustopp mit 400
Flüchtlingen 400 Flüchtlinge in einem
1600 Seelendorf wie würden Sie reagieren
wenn sie dort leben würden
naja ich würde natürlich Anteilnahme
zeigen für diejenigen die unter diesen
inhumanen Bedingungen dort ankommen und
das ist ja auch vorhin geschildert
worden
natürlich und andererseits würde ich
darüber nachdenken gerne tun würden und
was man politisch so sagt oder würden
Sie genauso reagieren wenn sie in den
Dorf leben würden nein ich würde so
reagieren weil natürlich ich begreife ja
die Herausforderung deswegen sage ich
die wohnverpflichtung für viele Kommunen
stellt eine unglaubliche Herausforderung
da die genau zu solchen Zuständen führt
deswegen muss sie aufgehoben werden und
deswegen muss aber auch darüber
nachgedacht werden wie ein Infrastruktur
investiert werden kann damit eben nicht
solche Container Dörfer entstehen oder
damit eben nicht ähm tonhallen in den
Schulen zur Verfügung gestellt werden
für die sammeln Unterkünfte und so
weiter und so fort dass der
gesamtpolitische Aufgabe aber in der
konkreten Situation ist das natürlich
das verstehe ich eine Zuspitzung vor Ort
sicherlich auch für viele eine wirkliche
Herausforderung aber es dient ja nicht
da immer weiter Öl ins Feuer zu gießen
Kopf
zu bringen
1600 Leute dort vorne gewohnt haben uns
kommt 400 aus Syrien Afghanistan und
sonst woher Spitze Beschreibung dessen
sozusagen was ich gerade Versuche
darzustellen und deswegen muss man
natürlich über andere politische
Lösungen Nachdenken an dieser Stelle
auch
in den Städten neben mir wir können es
vielleicht ganz recht sein aber wenn Sie
die wohnverpflichtung Aufnehmen von
denen es ja jetzt schon Ausnahmen gibt
also wenn jemand sagt ich habe da mein
Onkel lassen wir den sofort dorthin
lassen aber wenn Sie das grundsätzlich
aufheben die Residenzpflicht dann haben
sie alle in den großen Städten und das
werden nicht mehr schultern können
erleben Sie gerade Herr Baldauf das auf
dem mir sowieso zumindest eine Städten
angespannten Wohnungsmarkt eine
zusätzliche Konkurrenz entstanden ist
durch den massiven Zuzug ja dem ist so
tatsache ist auch dass in den letzten
Jahren der soziale Wohnungsbau nicht
ausreichend vorangetrieben wurde das
stimmt wir haben auch viel zu wenige
Kindertagesstätten für die Gesetzeslage
die wir haben die Schulen sind nicht
alle die modernsten das sind ja alles
Gebäude die über die Kommune auch
bezahlt werden das ist richtig aber fakt
ist nun mal dass das die Situation ist
und wenn wir jetzt überlegen und sagen
da wir bauen jetzt nur noch damit wir
noch mehr aufnehmen können dann frage
ich mal umgekehrt ja brauchen wir
vielleicht mal erst für unsere auch
schauen wir mal dass es ausreichend
Kindertagesstätten gibt ausreichend
Schulen viele andere
Infrastruktureinrichtungen wie
Sporthallen und vieles mehr da liegt es
ja auch im Argen im ganzen Land und
deshalb glaube ich dass wir das wir
können da lange Reden Baumaßnahmen
dauern ja auch dass wir jetzt im Moment
kurzfristig dem Landrat nur helfen
können um das zu wiederholen wenn man
jetzt
waren die flüchtlingskrise die
Wohnungsnot in den Städten ja gut ich
kann mir gut vorstellen wenn man dann so
Bilder sieht in irgendwo von denen die
dann kommen und sind schon moderne
Gebäude da das auch noch mal Anreiz ich
glaube das äh die Wohnungskrise vor
allem dadurch entstanden ist und die
Wohnungssuche dadurch eingetreten ist
das einfach nicht mehr in den
Wohnungsbau investiert worden ist die
bundesagen
dann machen wir so in der Gegenwart fest
äh die zuständige Ministerin dieser
Regierung musste klein dort zugestehen
dass sie es nicht schaffen die 400.000
Wohnung neu zu bauen in diesem Jahr
diese bauen wollte diese Bundesregierung
sie hat es für jedes Jahr versprochen
und sie hat in jedem Jahr hunderttausend
Sozialwohnungen versprochen das
funktioniert es passiert einfach nicht
die bleiben da irgendwie so hinter ihren
selbst gesteckten Zielen zurück die
Analyse
wir haben den Platz nicht wir haben die
Wohnung nicht wir haben die Unterkünfte
nicht und jetzt na wie schaffen wir die
indem wir sozusagen tatsächlich diese
Ziele dann auch umsetzen deswegen sagen
wir als Link wir brauchen 250.000
Sozialwohnungen in Deutschland es gibt
im Moment ein riesenbedarf an Leistung
bezahlbarem Wohnraum
nicht hinterher bei allen politischen
Versagen dass dahinter steckt aber wir
kommen jetzt mit dem Bauen nicht
hinterher unter anderem auch in Berlin
wo sie ja lange genug mitregierte haben
wir kommen mit dem Bauen nicht hinterher
und jetzt sagen Sie ja den Zuzug sollen
wir aber nicht stoppen sondern wir
sollen mehr bauen passt nicht
logischerweise müssen wir mehr bauen
weil das Wohnungsprobleme jetzt völlig
unabhängig von den geflüchteten die nach
Deutschland kommen schon bestanden hat
und weiterhin besteht und das
Wohnungsproblem im Griff zu kriegen muss
man entsprechend bauen und dann stellt
sich diese Frage doch als eine zweite
ord in dort Menschen leben die bereit
sind geflüchtete aufzunehmen in ihren
Wohnungen wenn sie darin leben dann
sozusagen funktioniert das doch
natürlich trägt Wohnungsbau dazu bei
dass auch in dieser Stelle die Kommunen
entlastet werden und dann private zum
Beispiel einsteigen wie wir bei den aus
dem Ukraine Krieg geflüchteten
richtigerweise über eine Million
Menschen im letzten Jahr die nach
Deutschland gekommen sind und diese
meisten sind privat untergekommen egal
behalten Sie das für realistisch jedes
Jahr müssten wir ja eine Großstadt
errichten in Deutschland zusätzlich nein
es ist überhaupt nicht realistisch wenn
man sieht wie es schon jetzt
aus verschiedensten Gründen einfach
nicht genug gebaut wird und das ist auch
glaube ich nicht die Lösung zu sagen der
Staat baut jetzt und Sozialwohnungen der
Stadt muss die Voraussetzungen schaffen
das private bauen und dann muss man ihn
auch den ein oder anderen Keks mal da
liegen dass die tun auch was dafür die
bauen dann nämlich und wenn sie nur
kommen und diese ganzen Kekse verteilen
wollen sind die Kekse auch schnell bald
weg bzw es entstehen keine neuen mehr
das heißt der Staat macht jetzt gerade
genau das Gegenteil siehe Herrn habix
heizungsplan der in der jetzigen
Wohnungsnot vollkommen absurd ist noch
mal zusätzlich Wohnbauten zu verteuern
indem man bei Neubauten vorschreibte
facto-vorschreibt eine Wärmepumpe
einbauen zu müssen die einfach viel
teurer ist und die auch nach dem
jetzigen Strommix eigentlich im Winter
eine Kohleheizung ist und sicherlich
nicht klimafreuen die sie im Moment auch
gar nicht geliefert kriegen kleine
Ausflug und zurück äh zu unserem
Kernthema und wir schauen noch mal auf
die Menschen die dazu uns gekommen sind
in den vergangenen Monaten kann man
sehen aus der Perspektive
Fürstenfeldbruck einmal drauf geschaut
wir uns fehlt tatsächlicher übereinander
Arbeitskräften und die Bundesregierung
sagt jetzt genau wie er schürdemann in
der jetzigen Situation Mensch wir
brauchen ja Menschen die arbeiten hier
in Deutschland in den nächsten Jahren
und Jahrzehnten bei wie vielen würden
Sie sagen das klappt
ja wir brauchen dringend die
Arbeitsmigration das ist ganz klar nur
die werden wir nicht jetzt bei dem
ungeregelten Zuwanderung finden wenn
sich ein Ingenieur aus Libyen bei uns
bewirbt ist das wunderbar wenn er dann
zu BMW kommt der bekommt auch gleich
einen grünen Wald dann die wunderbare
Wohnung da kümmert sich BMW drum
überhaupt kein Problem nicht aber das
ist doch nicht das Thema über das wir
reden wir brauchen auch außer BMW
Ingenieure auch andere im einfachen
Arbeitsmarkt Menschen aber es ist alles
mögliche heute wenn einer einen
Arbeitsvertrag vorweist bei einer
Bäckerei er kann kommen da müssen eher
die Botschaften übrigens mal schneller
werden die sind sehr langsam da im
Ausland der wunderbar sich oft die
würden wir alle brauchen aber die können
wir nicht generieren aus der
ungeregelten Zuwanderung nach dem Motto
dazu wie man ein paar aus paar welche
brauchen kann nicht weil die Ausbildung
fehlt weil jegliche Ausbildung fehlt
weil der Arbeitswille fehlt naja das ist
unterschiedlich äh das will ich nicht
über einen Kamm scheren es gibt Menschen
die sehr arbeitswillig sind auch für
einfache Tätigkeiten in der Tat ist der
Ausbildungsstand
sehr deutlich anders als bei uns in
Deutschland die es ist
Anforderungsprofil ist das heißt da
müsste man sehr lange hinarbeiten
sozusagen um die Menschen in die
Qualifikation zu bringen es gibt
übrigens da Statistiken wie viel man
schon integriert hat und so weiter muss
man mal gucken was in den Arbeitsmarkt
integriert bedeutet die Bundesagentur
erklärt als in den Arbeitsmarkt
integriert wenn jemand einen Tag in
lohnabhängiger Beschäftigung
tätig ist danach fällt er vom Schirm
nicht und sagt okay Haken dahinter also
das muss man alles sehr genau Fragen aus
der Praxis könnten sie das etwa
prozentual sagen bei so und so vielen
hat es geklappt zumindest einen Tag
ziehen Arbeit zu bringen ja aus Siemens
aus der aus der Zuwanderung die einfach
so erfolgreich
habe ich die Zahlen nicht genau im Kopf
sicher unter 20 Prozent in die Richtung
eher Richtung 10 bis 12 Prozent ist das
eine Erfolg Ralf Stegner sagte das
kürzlich in der Talkshow dass doch
relativ niedrige zahnzeit doch toll dass
so viele Arbeiten ist das ein Erfolg ein
erster Schritt mir ganz kurz auch mit
einer Anekdote Antworten und dann kurz
ganz kurz das wirklich sehr schnell
heute sozusagen ähm habe ich über jemand
gesprochen in einer anderen Situation
Kelvin ist der Spitzname das ein junger
Nigerianer der seit 4 Jahren und
Würzburg lebt und dort als sozialpfleger
eine Ausbildung ist der kann morgen
schon wieder abgeschoben werden weil er
jetzt ein abschiebeschreiben sozusagen
gekriegt hat morgen findet die nächste
sammelabschiedung nach Nigeria das macht
vorne und hinten keinen Sinn weil der
ist wirklich komplette im Fußball und so
weiter er arbeitet ist in einem System
werden abgeschoben weil diese
pflichtgemäß noch melden und zum
abschiebeterin völlig richtig deswegen
sage ich 20 Prozent können nur an erster
Schritt sein aber wenn solche Fehler
passieren wie unter anderem bei Kelvin
dann ist das natürlich ein echtes
Problem aber natürlich finden wir auch
Leute die bereit sind genau eben solche
und wir haben ein Bedarf gerade in der
Pflege z.B in solchen systemrelevanten
Leuten erstmal eine Ausbildung auch
anzunehmen und dann natürlich
entsprechend auch dazu beizutragen dass
der Pflegenotstand die teilweise
Probleme mit Frauen haben die gehen aus
Afghanistan und Syrien in die Pflege
halten sie das halten Sie das für
realistisch
ich glaube wir müssen jetzt mal auf
eines aufpassen man darf beide Dinge
nicht vermengen das eine ist die Frage
Flucht und Asyl und das andere ist die
Frage Fachkräftegewinnung
Fachkräftegewinnung sind 400.000 das
stimmt das sind aber die qualifizierten
so dann kann man auch noch mal die Frage
stellen das ist länderaufgabe sind denn
diese Anerkennung der ausländischen
Abschlüsse sind die immer so clever weil
die Niveaus sind zum Teil auch so hoch
dass man mal fragen kann Erzieherin fünf
Jahre Ausbildung müsste man das nicht
kürzen aber wenn man das machen will
gezielte Fachkräfte Zuwanderung dann
bitte in den Arbeitsmarkt nicht in die
Sozialsystem dann kann es sein dass
unter denen die aus fluchtgründen zu uns
kommen welche dabei sind die outen sich
aber dadurch indem sie ihre Dinge
vorlegen können so weiße sie vorlegen
können oder ihr Qualifikation nachweisen
können und dann muss man darüber reden
ob sie da bleiben können deswegen großer
Ziffern
müssen natürlich auch ausbilden
Fachkräfte Mangel wird ja auch dadurch
behoben dass wir z.B Ausbildungsplätze
wieder schaffen das vor allem auch da an
dieser Stelle die Industrie wieder ihre
Verantwortung wahrnimmt das Kleidung
möglich leer stehende Ausbildungsplätze
genau
suchen an der Stelle wir müssen noch die
dann eine Brücke finden zwischen
existiert
nicht zu arbeiten
sollte man möglicherweise in den ersten
Jahren sogar zur Arbeit verpflichten
davon halte ich wenig ich glaube wir
müssen Anreize ja man kommen aus einer
Partei die immer mit Anreizen arbeitet
und nicht mit Verpflichtungen ich kann
mir zum Beispiel gut vorstellen sie
werden sich wundern natürlich gibt es an
der ein oder anderen Stelle auch
Situationen
ja
Ordnungspolitik haben wir auch mal sein
Regeln vorzugeben die dann passen ne
wenn wir eine Frage wie weit man da geht
schon Ludwig er hat so gesagt da haben
wir eine gute guten
Fachkräfte
Bedarf decken will dann fangen wir
vielleicht mal bei uns in Deutschland an
50.000 machen keinen Abschluss also
schon mal ein Problem dann gucken wir
mal dass uns ein eigenes Bildungssystem
funktioniert Nummer zwei gezielte
Zuwanderung warum kann man denn nicht
wie es die Amis wie ist die Kanadier
machen mit Punktesystem und anderen
Dingen in den Ländern wo man Personen
herbekommen kann also beispielsweise
Indien viele andere dort auch
Werbemaßnahmen ergreifen das hat aber
zunächst mit fluchtgründen nicht zu tun
und wenn jetzt jemand hierher kommt und
ist verfolgt dann kann er seine
Qualifikation nachweisen dagegen sagt ja
keiner was was aber nicht passieren darf
und das interessiert mich im Moment am
meisten ich habe letzte Woche gehört es
soll jetzt überlegt werden wenn einer 67
Jahre alt ist dann wird er automatisch
deutscher ja wer zahlt in dem die Rente
und aus welchen Beträgen heraus wer hat
die denn einbezahlt das ist mal die
erste Frage dann diese ganze Aufweichung
wir lassen die Menschen schneller
deutsche werden auch diejenigen die
illegal hierher gekommen sind über Jahre
hinweg nicht abgeschoben wurden aus ganz
unterschiedlichen Gründen die werden
dann plötzlich deutsche das reist uns
die Gesellschaft auseinander das
versteht kein Mensch und ich glaube da
müssen wir dran arbeiten ja die Menschen
die verfolgt werden die nehmen wir auf
und dann schauen wir unabhängig davon
wie lösen wir die 5000 fehlenden
Pflegekräfte auf wo kriegen wir die her
und wie machen wir das insgesamt und
zwar so dass die auch die Chance haben
den Abschluss zu kriegen und nicht nach
dem Motto so hoch würden sie abgezockt
oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
nehmen unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie